mes chers amis chers luron j'étais là
depuis le matin début de la réunion
puisque j'avais entendu au télé à la
radio que tout le monde allait se
déchirer donc comme j'ai l'habitude des
discussions difficiles au niveau de 27
et j'ai dit je mettre à l'arrière
si jamais ça va trop mal je vais essayer
d'avancer pour défendre pour que l'union
reste au sein des élèves mais je n'avais
pas besoin de le faire et je suis aussi
comblé à seule chose je vais vous dire
comme vous êtes au fond de la salle et
je fais toujours ça quand je vais dans
les différents pays
au niveau des partis j'étais assis au
dernier rang et j'écoutais un petit peu
les discours des uns et les autres
c'était merveilleux ce que j'ai entendu
des militantes qui m'ont dit mais nous
on est d'accord mais mme et il est
d'accord là devant nous on est d'accord
on applaudira avec avec force pour que
cette famine reste uni et avec ce que
j'ai entendu ce matin je vais vous dire
que je me réjouis d'écouter la
conclusion de laurent après m'en parler
un petit peu d'europe ce n'est pas
reprendre puisque je voudrais remercier
franck pouces et son équipe
tous les témoignages que vous avez dans
les semaines ou fête du travail
excellent et ce n'est pas facile c'est
beaucoup plus facile dans un congrès ou
dans une réunion comme aujourd'hui de
dire il faut il faut il faut il faut
après en étant médecin et quand on est à
malheureusement faut trouver des
compromis
ça c'est mon rôle en tant que président
du parti je suis pas un grand président
j'essaie d'être un grand animateur
c'est ce que je souhaite aussi au niveau
des responsables de l air aujourd'hui
nous avons besoin de beaucoup
d'animateurs
nous avons besoin de nourrir
et les français est nominé temps
n'attend que ça et nous allons les
retrouver très vite nous allons les
retrouver aux élections européennes
pourquoi vous avez dit laissez points
moi je peux signer en dessous juin dire
à laurent il ya deux minutes
moi je signe en dessous on change
quelques détails et tu as bien fait
laurent de faire les sept points à
l'airé discuter dans la france entière
et vous allez faire comme au niveau du
ppe début février
nous allons annoncer notre vrai
programme pour les élections
un deuxième point ces élections vont
être difficiles pour le ppe et vont être
difficiles connaît là tout le monde nous
attend au courant au tournant et chacun
dit c'est le bpe qui est responsable
parce que ça ne marche pas là ça marche
pas là c'est l'immigration celle
économique l'europe ne marche pas parce
que les pères de l'europe et tpe
mais nous sommes fiers de ce qui s'est
passé je ne vais pas reprendre les
chiffres que tu as dit ce matin
sinon je suis trop long et vous attendez
aussi le match mais les chiffres
démontrent tout ce qui a été fait
pendant 60 ans nous devons le dire
maintenant avant noël nous devons dire à
nos amis tous que le ppe a fait au
niveau de l'europe
prenons le problème de l'immigration
c'est un problème qui est un vrai
problème mais regardez quand même
l'évolution qui est arrivé au niveau de
l'immigration
maintenant nous devons avoir le courage
de dire rien ne sera plus comme avant
comment faisons autrement au niveau de
l'immigration l'immigration des réfugiés
est terminée et l'immigration qui est
actuellement co c'est soutenir les
gangsters internationaux sur le dos des
immigrés
ça me devons l'arrêter les amis sur le
terrorisme
là aussi je vous lance la réflexion
aujourd'hui sur le terrorisme
nous devons voir ce qui se passe je
crois vous en avez parlé ce matin et le
terrorisme va se développer en libye
j'ai vu un ancien premier ministre
libanais un jour il a dit président nous
n'avons pas besoin d'argent de l'europe
c'est la première fois que j'ai entendu
ça d'ailleurs nous avons assez de
richesses mais nous devons organiser le
pays pour que ces richesses soient bien
partagée et soit bien employé
sinon ces richesses seront utilisés par
des shs et isis pour la formation des
cadres pour nous combattre et combattre
l'afrique
ça c'est notre rôle dans les prochains
temps le deuxième grand problème
l'élargissement je vais être très franc
je ne suis pas une personne qui va dire
élargissement rappelez vous la dernière
campagne européenne que nous avons fait
les extrémistes nous ont dit oui le ppe
me faire entrer la turquie non nous
avons discuté avec la turquie et moi
j'ai toujours dit en tribunes mais
c'était personne n'écoutait ça tout le
monde disait de dpe de faire entrer la
turquie non nous avons travaillé et nous
travaillons avec la turquie et la
turquie s'est rendu compte qu'elle n'est
pas européenne qu'il ne peut pas rentrer
au niveau du respect de nos valeurs au
niveau de l'union européenne
cela doit quand même nous encourager à
faire un partenariat privilégié comme
l'a toujours dit nicolas sarkozy pour
travailler avec la turquie parce que
c'est un grand pays au niveau des
balkans 20 millions d'habitants
à l'intérieur des frontières européens
c'est mon plus grand souci et je passe
un temps fou au niveau de ces pays du
wagon fadela bodmer s'est levé si vous
voyez votre femme vous toucher 250 euros
de l'arabie saoudite
vous avez la turquie
vous allez la russie c'est une
déstabilisation de la région pour
déstabiliser l'europe
demain tous les jeunes que ça soit en
albanie ou ailleurs sont en train de
quitter leur pays
pourquoi parce qu'il n'y a pas d'état de
droit il n'y a pas de justice
indépendante
il n'y a que de la corruption si nous
n'intervenons pas dans ces pays à
l'intérieur de nos frontières mes amis
on peut avoir entre 4 et 5 millions de
réfugiés très rapidement sans contrôler
quoi que ce soit
j'ai pas dit qu'il fallait élargir mais
nous devons les aider à mettre en place
un état de droit une justice
indépendante et combattre la corruption
pour que le pis se développer
économiquement
sinon nous allons subir et je peux vous
dire que ce qui s'est passé dans cette
région
la dernière guerre que vous connaissez
elle n'est pas très loin
moi j'y suis les tensions sont énormes
ceux qui sont encore des modérés qui a
envie d'avancer au niveau économique
sont obligés de partir se parle des
jeunes reste qui ceux qui ont envie de
se battre encore ensemble comme
l'histoire l'a démontré à quelques
années alors là aussi nous avons un
devoir de les aider à mettre en place je
répète l'état de droit la justice
indépendante et combattre la corruption
pour que ces peuples puissent vivre chez
eux c'est nos voisins je ne lance
simplement la réflexion est ce que je
lance mon cher l'euro il faut que nous
au niveau du parti nous nous engagions
qui est deux ou trois responsables qui
vont voir les responsables de ces partis
dans leur pays
comme je dis à ma femme quand je vais
dans cette région je vais voir mes
gangsters j'ose le dire
préaux mais il faut les voir il faut
leur parler un langage de vérité et
c'est cela ça le rend c'est très
important au niveau des pays des balkans
au lieu de parler élargissement des
balkans parlons comment nous allons
pouvoir les aider à mettre en place un
système européen et nos valeurs
européennes dans cette région qui est
très proche et qui peut
nous coûter très cher s'il ya le moindre
problème d'insécurité savait que la
sécurité les services peuvent travailler
encore beaucoup plus ensemble
là vous avez déjà discuté ce matin
maintenant je parle d'un sujet favori
l'agriculture la sécurité alimentaire
c'est un dossier qu'on est en train
d'essayer de faire couler pourrait
encore compter sur moi aussi longtemps
que je serai responsable que je vais le
défendre
et là je pense à nos amis des dom qui
sont dans cette salle je peux vous dire
aujourd'hui que la semaine dernière avec
michel dantin nous avons sauvé
l'enveloppent et d'hommes à la prochaine
réflexion sur le cadre financier on ne
touchera pas à l' enveloppe au niveau
des dom
nous avons besoin aussi de budget même
si monsieur m'a conduit on attend après
les élections salez le ppe depuis un an
et près nos amis au niveau du parlement
sont prêts à avancer à le travailler à
la voter avant la fin du mandat
pourquoi at on peur pourquoi monsieur
marois a peur du budget le budget peut
être voté et si l'on pense qu'on est
très grand et qu'on peut tout changer au
niveau de l'europe d'ailleurs emportant
je vais vous dire j'ai trouvé le slogan
le slogan le nouveau slogan pour la
campagne laurence et on va tout changer
point et tu ne répète tous les jours et
c'est bon mais on sait pas ce qui va
changer donc
le budget il faut qu'il soit fait avant
les élections après les élections nous
allons avoir une commission stagiaires
en 2019 si nous arrivons à la mettre en
place ce que personne ne connaît
aujourd'hui l'issue des élections
commission stagiaires donc incapable de
proposer quoi que ce soit un parlement
où sais pas où sont les majorités que
vont dire les agriculteurs surtout la
recherche qui a besoin d'une vision et
comment il peut engager les faux
européen que mon dire tous ces
programmes qui sont sur la table
erasmus et les autres si nous n'avons
pas de vision budgétaire donc là aussi
faisons le budget votons le budget et
après mettons une phrase en dessous
qu'on est capable de le revoir à partir
de 2020 par exemple ça ne change pas ça
ne remet en cause personne et mais
montrons notre capacité qui est une
certaine continuité au niveau de notre
budget et cheyrou en moi je n'ai pas la
facilité et citations comme toi mais
j'en ai une et je prends toujours
einstein qui disait la folie c'est de
faire toujours la même chose et
s'attendre à un résultat différent
non
[Applaudissements]
et je vais vous sur faire sourire une
deuxième fois
vous savez que avec jacques chirac j'ai
géré la crise de la vache folle en
france qui a failli anéantir
l'agriculture c'est pour ça d'ailleurs
que je suis devenu député européen
c'est que celui qui m'a mis sur la liste
à la 7e place
parce que j'avais géré la crise de la
vache folle je vois mon ami christian et
donc qu'est-ce que j'ai toujours dit au
moment de la crise de la vache folle
j'ai toujours dit on ne peut plus
employer les recettes du passé pour
résoudre les problèmes du présent et
ceux qui le font et échoue nous devons
donc innover adapté en ces différences à
différemment mais aussi avoir le penser
de ne pas tout détruire ce que nous
avons déjà donc ça je crois que c'est
très bien et que cette belle idée des
grands projets les bonnes intentions
c'est très bien mais après les chers
amis et les députés européens le savent
encore plus que moi
il faut les partager à 27 et ça c'est un
travail de tous les jours et pour que la
france existe et je suis pour que la
france existe
eh ben il faut la travailler tous les
jours partager c'est un travail de titan
puisque après ici je vais retourner en
allemagne puisque l'allemagne à des
difficultés énormes au sein de nos deux
partis de droite a avec l'opposition
donc c'est effectivement en un travail
et non je ne voudrais pas être trop long
il faut réformer faut toujours réformer
c'est un travail de longue haleine qui
doit se faire au jour le jour en
coopération avec nos partenaires
européens
en écoutant leurs demandes et en
cherchant les compromis nous devons
aussi nous donner les moyens de nos
ambitions
et là mes chers amis c'est le budget on
ne peut pas faire avec le même budget
une politique sur l'immigration une
politique agricole qu'on veut conserver
une politique de défense
mes chers amis nous devons passer à la
caisse et nous devons ouvrir notre
portefeuille
ça aussi c'est la vérité
sans faire de dette comme on l'a fait
cette année en france donc là aussi
c'est la réflexion que nous devons mener
j'ai un gros souci au niveau de l'italie
pas parce que sont arrivés les
extrémistes ça c'est peut-être pour nous
de voir comment ils sont capables de
travailler on a déjà vu une première
fois avec 6 passes personne ne le dit la
presse ne le répète jamais les
propositions de type race vous les
prenez au moment ils ont gagné les
élections
vous les comparez aujourd'hui c'est très
très intéressant c'est le contraire qui
n'a dû faire quand il est entré
effectivement en action pour l'italie
pour l'italie nous avons un risque est
beaucoup plus loin aujourd'hui arrêter
les bateaux
on peut même dire dans une bonne chose
ça provoque ça nous oblige de changer
demain quand ils devront et et
équilibrer leurs comptes
et s'ils veulent appliquer leur
programme électoral de droite et de
gauche qui sont sur la table
et bien mes chers amis vous savez ce que
ça va donner ça va donner un déficit et
ça va faire des pauses et des banques
italiennes
leur bilan est derrière l'italie vous
savez quel pays va être touchée en
premier
eh bien c'est la france donc nous avons
tous intérêt aussi à regarder de ce côté
là je vais terminer puisque vous avez
encore sinon je pourrais continuer à
parler mais je voudrais vous parler deux
minutes de notre président laurent tu
sais nous avons une connivence et elle
est très forte
tous les quinze jours on est au
téléphone
bruno nous nous voyons les siens ne
voyons chez rare chez nous le voyons
nous sommes inquiets il faut que la
france retrouve ce qu'elle avait été au
niveau de la construction européenne
et pour cela nous devons travailler nous
devons faire abstraction
nous devons faire abstraction des
problèmes de personnes nous devons
travailler en équipe
sinon nous n'existons pas
moi j'ai combien de pays je prends la
slovaque et j'ai cinq parties au niveau
du centre droit chacun fait 4 % 4 x 100
x a fait vente 20 % des électeurs 0
députés parce qu'il faut 5 % pour entrer
c'est quand même pas sa tournée en
france donc travaillons faisons
confiance à notre président tu nous ne
sommes pas ça d'accord sur certains
points on les discute c'est ça la
démocratie
c'est ça le parti et je suis très
content qu'on s'est retrouvés ici et mon
cher laurent si tu as encore besoin de
moi j'étais tout petit expérience avec
les vingt-sept je suis prêt à revenir
autant de fois pour que notre parti soit
de nouveau demain le grand parti au
niveau de la prof merci
[Applaudissements]